Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A few years ago, we have mainly seen neural
network-based techniques being used for image
classification.
This means that they were able to recognize
objects, for instance, animals and traffic
signs in images.
But today, with the incredible pace of machine
learning research, we now have a selection
of neural network-based techniques for not
only classifying images, but, also, synthesizing
them!
The images that you see here and throughout
this video is generated by one of these learning-based
methods.
But of course, in this series, we are always
obsessed with artistic control, or, in other
words, how much of a say we have in the creation
of these images.
After all, getting thousands and thousands
of images without any overarching theme or
artistic control is hardly useful for anyone.
One way of being able to control the outputs
is to use a technique that is capable of image
translation.
What you see here is a work by the name CycleGAN!
It could transform apples into oranges, zebras
into horses, and more.
It was called CycleGAN because it introduced
a cycle consistency loss function.
This means that if we convert a summer image
to a winter image, and then back to a summer
image, we should get the same input image
back, or at least, something very similar.
If our learning system obeys this principle,
the output quality of the translation is going
to be significantly better.
Today, we are going to study a more advanced
image translation technique that takes this
further.
This paper is amazingly good at daytime image
translation.
It looks at a selection of landscape images,
and then, as you see here, it learns to reimagine
our input photos as if they were taken at
different times of the day.
I love how clouds form, and move over time
in the synthesized images, and the night sky
with the stars is also truly a sight to behold.
But wait, CycleGAN and many other followup
works did image translation, this also does
image translation, so, what’s really new
here?
Well, one, this work proposes a novel upsampling
scheme that helps creating output images with
lots and lots of detail.
Two, it can also create not just a bunch of
images a few hours apart, but it can also
make beautiful timelapse videos, where the
transitions are smooth.
Oh my goodness.
I love this.
And three, the training happens by shoveling
20 thousand landscape images into the neural
network, and it becomes able to perform this
translation task without labels.
This means that we don’t have to explicitly
search for all the daytime images and tell
the learner that these are daytime images,
and these other images are not.
This is amazing because the algorithm is able
to learn by itself, without labels, but it
is also easier to use because we can feed
in lots and lots more training data without
having to label these images correctly.
As a result, we now know that this daytime
translation task is used as a testbed to demonstrate
that this method can be reused for other kinds
of image translation tasks.
The fact that it can learn on its own and
still compete with other works in this area
is truly incredible.
Due to this kind of generality, it can also
perform other related tasks, for instance,
it can perform style transfer, or in other
words, not just change the time of day, but
reimagine our pictures in the style of famous
artists.
I think with this paper, we have a really
capable technique on our hands that is getting
closer and closer to the point where they
can see use in mainstream software packages
and image editors.
That would be absolutely amazing.
If you have a closer look at the paper, you
will see that it tries to minimize 7 things
at the same time.
What a time to be alive!
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
Here, they show you how to build a proper
Convolutional Neural Network for image classification,
and how to visualize the performance of your
model.
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
Their system is designed to save you a ton
of time and money, and it is actively used
in projects at prestigious labs, such as OpenAI,
Toyota Research, GitHub, and more.
And, the best part is that if you are an academic
or have an open source project, you can use
their tools for free.
It really is as good as it gets.
Make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for their long-standing
support and for helping us make better videos
for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!